This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the late 16th century, a playwright named Thomas Kidd wrote a tragedy. It was about an aristocrat who seeks revenge after his son is murdered. Murder! Murder! Help her on the move! Come, stop her mouth! Away with her. The play was called the Spanish tragedy, and it is still produced occasionally today.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在16世纪晚期，一位名叫托马斯·基德的剧作家写了一部悲剧。讲的是一个贵族在儿子被谋杀后寻求复仇的故事。谋杀！谋杀！快帮帮她！快，闭上她的嘴！带她走。这部剧名为《西班牙悲剧》，今天偶尔仍会被搬上舞台。
What outcries plucked me from my naked bed, and chill my throbbing heart with trembling fear, which never danger yet could not before. Thomas Kitt's play was popular in its day, but unless you're an Elizabethan scholar, you probably haven't heard of the playwright. You may have heard about one of his contemporaries though. William Shakespeare. As Thomas Kitt's Curia flatlined after the Spanish tragedy, Shakespeare wrote masterpiece after masterpiece. I knew him, I knew him, I knew him. Followed by comedies, Reason and love keep little company together nowadays. Followed by historical dramas and more.
是什么尖叫声将我从赤裸的床上惊醒，又是什么让颤抖的恐惧冰冻了我悸动的心？这恐惧是此前从未因任何危险而有过的。托马斯·基德的剧作在当时很受欢迎，但除非你是伊丽莎白时代的学者，否则你可能没听说过这位剧作家。不过，你可能听说过他的同时代人之一，威廉·莎士比亚。随着托马斯·基德的戏剧在《西班牙悲剧》之后归于沉寂，莎士比亚却一部接一部地创作出旷世杰作。我认识他，我认识他，我认识他。随后是喜剧，如今理智与爱情鲜少结伴同行。接着是历史剧等等。
Love is not love which alters when it alteration finds or bends with the remover to remove. Shakespeare's plays have been translated into dozens of languages. They continue to be performed four hundred years after he wrote them. Even more than that, his words have become so much a part of our lives that we all quote him without realizing it. Love is blind comes from Shakespeare, so does faint-hearted and sea-change and too much of a good thing. When you say all that glitters is in gold or this method in his madness. You're quoting Shakespeare.
爱非爱，若遇改变即改变，或随移情者而移。莎士比亚的戏剧已被翻译成几十种语言。在他创作四百年后的今天，这些戏剧仍在不断上演。不仅如此，他的词句已经深深融入我们的生活，以至于我们常常在不知不觉中引用他。“爱是盲目的”出自莎士比亚，“畏缩不前”、“沧海桑田”以及“物极必反”也是如此。当你顺口说出“闪光的并非全都是金子”或者“疯狂之中自有条理”时。你就是在引用莎士比亚。
What explains the gulf between Thomas Kidd's one-hit wonder playwriting career and William Shakespeare's sustained success? And what explains the similar chasms we see between performers in many domains today? In art, and in in sports and in music. What makes Shakespeare Shakespeare? Or Michael Jordan, Michael Jordan? Or Taylor Swift? Taylor Swift. This week on Hidden Brain, we wrap up our series Success 2.0 with new research that aims to unpack a mystery. What's the secret to repeated and enduring success? In a number of fields of human performance, success is distributed very unevenly. Mathematicians call these power law distributions.
是什么解释了托马斯·基德那“昙花一现”的剧作家生涯与威廉·莎士比亚持久成功之间的巨大鸿沟？又是什么解释了当今许多领域的表演者之间存在的类似巨大差距？在艺术、体育和音乐领域。是什么造就了莎士比亚之所以成为莎士比亚？或者是迈克尔·乔丹之于迈克尔·乔丹？又或是泰勒·斯威夫特之于泰勒·斯威夫特？本周的《隐藏对话》，我们通过旨在解开一个谜团的新研究，为我们的“成功2.0”系列画上句号。在人类表现的许多领域中，成功分配得极其不均，这其中的秘诀是什么？数学家称之为幂律分布。
If you look at all the accomplishments in a given field, Emmy awards, Super Bowl Championships, hit plays, a handful of superstars account for a disproportionate share of the spoils. The rest of us are lucky to even have fleeting success. Most writers, for example, never get their books published. Of the ones that do, a small number become bestsellers. And among the writers who produce bestsellers, a very tiny fraction go on to produce lots and lots of bestsellers. Most basketball players never end up in the NBA. But of those who do, a small number become stars.
如果你审视特定领域中的所有成就——艾美奖、超级碗冠军、热门戏剧——一小撮超级巨星占据了压倒性的战利品份额。我们其余的人能获得短暂的成功就已经很幸运了。例如，大多数作家永远无法出版他们的书。在那些得以出版的作家中，只有少数人成为畅销书作家。而在产出畅销书的作家中，只有极小的一部分人能够继续产出大量畅销书。大多数篮球运动员最终都进不了NBA。但在那些进入NBA的人当中，只有少数人成为了明星。
And a very tiny fraction of those become household names. Well, you might say, I know why Shakespeare and Taylor Swift are so popular. They're really talented, or they were really lucky. But the chasm between total obscurity and being a one-hit wonder, and the chasm between being a one-hit wonder, and the cousin between being a one-hit wonder and those who have sustained success is so great that luck and talent seem like incomplete explanations. Across many domains, from entertainment to sports to technology, there are performers, creators and innovators who seem to have an instinct for greatness.
而其中极小的一部分人成为了家喻户晓的名字。好吧，你可能会说，我知道为什么莎士比亚和泰勒·斯威夫特如此受欢迎了。他们真的很有才华，或者他们真的很幸运。但是，从籍籍无名到昙花一现的鸿沟，从昙花一现到拥有持久成功者之间的鸿沟，是如此巨大，以至于运气和才华似乎成了不完整的解释。在从娱乐、体育到技术的许多领域中，总有一些表演者、创作者和创新者，他们似乎对伟大有着一种本能。
What can we learn from them? Today, we'll explore the psychology of creativity and success by examining the stories of two filmmakers whose work you know. Their story begins some 50 years ago. In the summer of 1977, a quirky sci-fi film became a global phenomenon. Star Wars was a story about an intergalactic civil war. It was packed with lots of drama and even more action. I'm Luke Skywalker, I'm here to rescue you. I'm here to rescue you. I've got your R2 unit. I'm here with Ben Kenobi. Ben Kenobi, where is it? Come on. There were aliens, spaceships, lightsabers.
我们能从他们身上学到什么？今天，我们将通过审视两位你熟悉其作品的电影制片人的故事，来探讨创造力和成功的心理学。他们的故事始于大约50年前。在1977年的夏天，一部古怪的科幻电影成了一种全球现象。《星球大战》讲述了一个星系间内战的故事。它充满了戏剧性，甚至有更多的动作场面。我是卢克·天行者，我是来救你的。我是来救你的。我拿到了你的R2装置。我和本·克诺比在一起。本·克诺比，它在哪？快点。里面有外星人、飞船、光剑。
And of course, there was the Force, a mysterious energy that bound the universe. The Force will be with you, always. The movie earned over 400 million dollars. Its writer, director and proprietor George Lucas was a graduate of the film school at the University of Southern California. After his massive success he began planning the sequel to Star Wars, the movie was titled The Empire Strikes Back. George Lucas wanted to build an entire franchise around Star Wars, but he didn't want to direct the sequel himself. He set his heart on an alternate director, a professor at USC who had made an impression
当然，还有原力——一种将整个宇宙联系在一起的神秘能量。原力将与你同在，永远。这部电影票房收入超过4亿美元。它的编剧、导演兼拥有者乔治·卢卡斯毕业于南加州大学电影学院。在他取得巨大成功之后，他开始筹划《星球大战》的续集，这部电影名为《帝国反击战》。乔治·卢卡斯想要围绕《星球大战》打造一个完整的特许经营宇宙，但他不想自己导演这部续集。他一心想要一位备选导演，一位在电影学院给他留下深刻印象的南加州大学教授。
on him in film school. There was just one problem. The professor wasn't a star was fan. In fact, Irvin Kirschner thought George Lucas was out of his mind. He had formed this impression before the original movie was released when he sat in on a viewing. In an interview with Hollywood's master storytellers, Irvin Kirschner described seeing George Lucas's creation for the very first time.
这里只有一个问题。这位教授并不是“星战”迷。事实上，欧文·克什纳认为乔治·卢卡斯疯了。他在原创电影上映前的一次试映会上就留下了这种印象。在接受好莱坞大师级故事片导演的采访时，欧文·克什纳描述了自己第一次看到乔治·卢卡斯作品时的情景。
We thought this is terrible. This is dreadful. What's he doing? He's crazy. It's a comic book. People jumping around, hanging around these odd creatures. What's he? God's going to lose a shirt in this. Fox is financing this piece of junk. Oh, we were sick for George, sick. Of course, Irvin Kirshner was wrong. The movie was a hit. But when George Lucas asked him to direct the Empire Strikes Back, he said no. In time, however, he gave in. In May 1980, the sequel was released. It is your destiny.
我们当时觉得这太糟糕了。这太可怕了。他在干什么？他疯了。这简直是一本漫画书。人们跳来跳去，围着这些奇怪的生物晃悠。他在搞什么？天哪，他在这部片子上要赔个精光。福克斯居然在资助这件垃圾。哦，我们为乔治感到难受，太难受了。当然，欧文·克什纳猜错了。这部电影大获成功。但当乔治·卢卡斯邀请他导演《帝国反击战》时，他拒绝了。不过随着时间的推移，他最终妥协了。1980年5月，续集上映了。这就是你的命运。
Join me and together we can rule the galaxy's father and son. Like Star Wars, it became a smashing success. It was the highest-grossing film in 1980 and earned over $400 million worldwide. Together, Irvin Kirschner and George Lucas made what some argue is the greatest film in the Star Wars franchise. You could say that 1980 was the year of Star Wars, but that same year, another film made its way into theaters. You want the solution to inflation? High friends, Marshall Lucky here for New Deal use cars where we're battling inflation. Use cars was a low-brow comedy that followed the story of a sleazy car salesman who had dreams of getting into politics. It was packed with ranch and gallows humour.
加入我，这样我们作为父子就能一起统治这个星系。就像《星球大战》一样，它取得了巨大的成功。它是1980年票房最高的电影，全球票房超过4亿美元。欧文·克什纳和乔治·卢卡斯联手打造了某些人所认为的《星球大战》系列中最伟大的电影。你可以说1980年是“星球大战年”，但就在同年，另一部电影走进了影院。你想要解决通胀的办法吗？嗨，朋友们，我是为“新政二手车”代言的马歇尔·拉克奇，在这里我们要对抗通胀。二手车是一部低俗喜剧，讲述了一个油滑的汽车销售员梦想涉足政坛的故事。它充斥着粗俗和黑色幽默。
I watched Uscars recently. It feels like three movies packed into one. A manic energy runs through the film and the story flies off in different directions. The characters are highly driven, but also unpleasant. I found myself rooting against all of them. Used cars was not a good movie. To put it less kindly, it was a flop. The movie critic Roger Ebert gave the movie two out of four stars. He said there were too many plot lines, too many characters, it didn't make sense. Critics slammed the movie's writer and director, a young filmmaker named Robert Zamekis. He was a graduate of the USC Film School too, but while urban Kushner's career choices
我最近看了《二手车》。感觉它就像是把三部电影压缩成了一部。一种狂热的能量贯穿整部电影，故事向着不同的方向飞驰。角色们极具进取心，但也令人讨厌。我发现自己情不自禁地希望他们所有人都倒霉。《二手车》可不是一部好电影。换个不那么好听的说法，它是一部彻底的灾难片。影评人罗杰·埃伯特给这部电影打了四星中的两星。他说片中的故事线太多，人物太多，根本说不通。影评人们猛烈抨击这部电影的编剧兼导演，一个名叫罗伯特·泽米吉斯的年轻电影人。他也是南加州大学电影学院的毕业生，但如果说欧文·克什纳的职业选择谨慎而一丝不苟，罗伯特·泽米吉斯则喜欢挑战极限。在《二手车》之前，他导演了一部名为《我想要握住你的手》的音乐剧。故事背景设定在1964年，讲述了一群决心见到披头士乐队的青少年的故事。大约在同一时期，他联合编剧了一部名为《1941》的电影，这是一部关于日本袭击珍珠港事件的喜剧，该事件将美国卷入了第二次世界大战。这是有史以来最具爆发力的喜剧大片《1941》。法安·阿罗扎肯！正如你所料，一个关于日本袭击美国的搞笑故事并没有被美国观众所接受。
were careful and meticulous, Robert Zemeckis liked to push the envelope. Before used cars, he directed a musical called I Wanna Hold Your Hand. Said in 1964, it told the story of a group of teenagers who were determined to meet the Beatles. Around the same time, he corrod a movie called 1941, a comedy about the Japanese attack on Pearl Harbor that brought the United States into World War II. The most explosive comedy spectacular ever filled, 1941. FAN AROZAKEN! As you might guess, a funny story about the Japanese attack on the United States didn't go down well with American audiences.
它也砸了。正当罗伯特·泽米吉斯的职业生涯陷入挣扎时，欧文·克什纳推出了另一部热门作品《巡弋飞弹》。这也是一部续集。这一次是极为热门的詹姆斯·邦德系列。这部电影在商业上取得了成功，票房收入达到1.6亿美元。到这个时候，我们故事中的两位导演都在好莱坞确立了声誉。欧文·克什纳已经成为了续集之王，一位拥有点金圣手的导演。
It flopped too. While Robert Zemeckis' career was struggling, Irwin Kushner released another hit, never say never again. It was another sequel. This time in the hugely popular James Bond franchise. The movie was a commercial success, grossing $160 million at the box office. Both the directors in our story by this point had established reputations in Hollywood. Irvin Kushner had become the king of sequels, a director with a magic touch.
罗伯特·泽米吉斯看起来却像个半吊子。他的电影和他的故事一样，古怪、前卫且毫无章法。你也可以说他同样有种点金圣手——不过是专门拍出票房毒药。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在20世纪80年代中期，好莱坞的两位电影人因不同的原因而成名。欧文·克什纳是一位资深导演，他执导了《帝国反击战》和《巡弋飞弹》，取得了巨大的商业成功。罗伯特·泽米吉斯则在树立一种截然不同的名声。
Robert Zamekis looked like a dilatant. His movies, like his stories, were weird, edgy and all over the place. You could say he had a magic touch too, for coming up with flops. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the mid 1980s, two filmmakers in Hollywood got famous for different reasons. Irvin Kushner was an established director who made the Empire Strikes Back and never say never again, huge commercial successes. Robert Zamekis was developing a different
在经历了一连串的失败后，他在好莱坞举步维艰，很难找到工作。他和他的写作搭档鲍勃·盖尔抽空休息了一段时间来重新调整。一天晚上，在圣路易斯探望父母时，鲍勃·盖尔无意中翻看着父亲的高中毕业纪念册。他产生了一个想法：如果能遇到年轻时的父母，会是什么样的体验？这是一个古怪的想法，所以理所当然地，罗伯特·泽米吉斯非常喜欢它。接下来的几个月里，两人开始创作一部关于家庭时间旅行的电影。他们兴奋地把这个故事带给了镇上的几乎每一家电影制片厂，但他们过去那些失败作所散发出的“恶臭”却抢先一步传到了那里。这份剧本被各大制片厂一次又一次地拒绝，大大小小总共大约被拒绝了40次。
kind of reputation. After a string of failures, he struggled to find work in Hollywood. Along with his writing partner, Bob Gale, he took some time off to regroup. One night, while visiting his parents in St. Louis, Bob Gale was flipping through his father's high school yearbook. He had a thought, what would it be like to meet the younger version of his parents? It was a weird idea, so of course, Robert Zamekis loved it. For months, the pair began writing a family time travel movie. They excitedly took the story to nearly every studio in town, but the stench of past flops preceded them. The script was rejected over and over by every major studio, some 40 times and all.
罗伯特·泽米吉斯后来描述了当时发生的事情。我认为决定不拍这部电影的原因在于，作为一名导演，我在票房上有着非常糟糕的记录。问题不仅仅在于电影人的声誉。各大制片厂给电影人列出了一长串他们的想法行不通的理由。时间旅行电影赚不了钱。故事太无聊了。里面没有足够的性爱元素。迪士尼看了一眼后表示他们不喜欢，因为这部电影太低俗了。
Robert Zemeckis later described what happened. I think the decision to not make the film was based on the fact that as a director I had a very poor track record at the box office. The problem wasn't just the filmmakers' reputation. The studios gave the filmmakers a long list of reasons their idea wouldn't work. Time travel movies don't make money. The story was too boring. There wasn't enough sex. Disney took a look at it and said they didn't like it because it was too raunchy.
关于这部电影的一切——情节、前提、编剧，都是非传统的。两位电影人将这个创意暂时搁置了。与此同时，罗伯特·泽米吉斯得到了另一个执导的机会。二十世纪福斯公司雇他去拍一部名为《魔茧》的科幻电影。在制作那部电影的同时，他偶然看到了另一份剧本。故事讲述了一位成功的浪漫小说家前往哥伦比亚，从绑匪手中拯救她姐姐的故事。它兼具喜剧和动作冒险元素。将一个受困女子送到电话亭的最低收费是400美元。
Everything about the movie, the plot, the premise, the writers, was unconventional. The filmmakers shelt the idea. Meanwhile, Robert Zemeckis was given another chance to direct. 20th century Fox hired him to work on a sci-fi movie called Cocoon. While he worked on that film, he came across another screenplay. It was about a successful romance novelist who travels to Columbia to save her sister from kidnappers. It was part comedy, part action adventure. By minimum price for taking a stranded woman to a telephone is $400.
你收375美元的旅行支票吗？美国运通的？当然收。罗伯特·泽米吉斯开始着手制作那部电影，同时还在执导《魔茧》。但当他把这部浪漫动作片早期版本拿给一位电影高管看时，情况并不顺利。似乎更多的失败即将来临。为了抢在灾难发生前摆脱干系，二十世纪福斯解雇了担任《魔茧》导演的罗伯特·泽米吉斯。
Will you take $375 in travel's text. American Express? Of course. Robert Zemeckis began to work on that film while also directing Cocoon. But when he showed an early version of the romantic action movie to a film executive, it didn't go well. It seemed like more failure was imminent. Eager to get ahead of a disaster, 20th Century Fox fired Robert Zemekis as the director of Cocoon.
他当时已经濒临成为好莱坞社会弃儿的边缘。但就在这时，意想不到的事情发生了。他的这部浪漫丛林冒险喜剧上映后大获成功。它就是《绿宝石》。这部电影是一部积极向上、异想天开的浪漫动作片。其中有着极大的乐趣。这是一部现代版的寻宝故事。在《绿宝石》取得空前成功之后，好莱坞开始用一种崭新的眼光来看待这位电影人的各种尝试。
He was perilously close to becoming a pariah in Hollywood. But then, something surprising happened. His romantic jungle adventure comedy was released and became a hit. It was called Romancing the Stone. The movie is an upbeat whimsical, romantic action picture. There's a great deal of fun. It's a modern day buried. After Romancing the Stone became a runaway success, Hollywood came to see the filmmakers' experiments in a new light. The fact that used cars and 1941 and Romancing the stone were all wildly different movies,
《二手车》、《1941》和《绿宝石》全都是风格迥异的电影，这意味着这位导演是无法被简单归类的。罗伯特·泽米吉斯是一个不守陈规的人。制片厂明白，这是一个需要长长的创作自由“牵引绳”才能发挥出最好水平的导演。这位导演利用自己新获得的明星地位，说道：“好吧，那部一直搁置在书架上的家庭时间旅行电影怎么样？”这一次，好莱坞高管们答应了。这部电影名叫《回到未来》。
meant that this was a director who could not be pigeonholed. Robert Zemeckis was an iconoclast. Studios understood that this was a director who needed a long leash of creative freedom in order to do his best work. Capitalizing on his newfound stardom, the director said, Okay, what about that family time travel movie that's been sitting on the shelf? This time, the Hollywood executives said yes. The movie was called Back to the Future.
它集爱情故事、家庭故事和动作冒险于一体。它既是科幻片，又是浪漫喜剧，而且百分之百是罗伯特·泽米吉斯的风格。我从看到它的那一刻起就爱上了它，而且从那以后每一次看，我都更爱它一点。贾斯廷·伯格（Justin Berg）是个影迷。对我来说，这是我能想象到的最接近完美的电影。第一部我大概看了有，不知道，将近70遍。70遍？现在大概有这么多了。
It was a love story and a family story and an action adventure rolled into one. It was part sci-fi, part romantic comedy, and all Robert Zameckis. I loved it for the moment I saw it, and every time ever since then watching it, I love it even more. Justin Berg is a fan. To me, it's the closest thing to a perfect movie that I could imagine. I've probably seen the first one, I don't know, close to 70 times. 70 times? Probably by now.
哦，天哪。现在已经很难数清了。70遍可能有点夸张，但贾斯廷确实看了很多遍这部电影。不看《回到未来》的时候，他是斯坦福大学商学院组织行为学的一名研究员。如果你对这部电影不熟悉，它讲述了一个少年的故事，
Oh my god. It's hard to count at this point. 70 times might be an exaggeration, but Justin has seen the movie a lot. When he's not watching back to the future, he's a researcher in organizational behavior at the Stanford Graduate School of Business. If you're not familiar with the movie, it tells the story of a teenager,
马蒂·麦克弗莱，他遇到了一位古怪的科学家，后者用一辆DMC德罗宁汽车改装成了一台时间机器。依我之见，既然你要把时间机器造进一辆车里，为什么不做得有型一点呢？而且！马蒂驾驶着德罗宁汽车进行了一次时空穿梭，回到了他父母上高中、且尚未成为情侣的过去。他看到未来的父亲差点被车撞，便一把将他推开。问题是，在原本的时间线上，那场车祸正是马蒂的妈妈和马蒂的爸爸相遇并最终走到一起成为情侣的契机。我记得，根据我的理论，你干扰了你父母的结合。他们就不会相遇，不会坠入爱河，不会结婚，也就不会有孩子。这就是为什么你哥哥现在看起来只是个普通朋友。
Marty McFly, who meets an eccentric scientist who has built a time machine out of a DMC delorean. The way I see it, if you're going to build a time machine into a car, why not do it some style? Besides! Marty takes a trip in the delorean and goes back in time to when his parents were in high school and before they were a couple. He sees his future dad almost being hit by a car and pushes him out of the way. The problem is that in the original timeline, the car accident was how Marty's mom and
他现在必须想办法让他的父母彼此坠入爱河。不管怎样，乔治，瓦伦丁，她真的很喜欢你。她让我告诉你，她想让你邀请她去参加…故事、角色、演技、节奏、这一切融合在一起的方式，音乐、美学，以及它是如何引人入胜、扣人心弦，还有你从电影的（你知道的）很早开始一直到结尾，是如何支持马蒂和博士的。这部电影承担了风险。其中一条情节线涉及马蒂遇到了自己的母亲。他的母亲当时是个青少年，而他们的年龄大致相当。令马蒂大跌眼镜的是，他的母亲没有迷恋上他的父亲，反而对他迷恋不已。我以前从没见过紫色的内裤，卡尔文。
Marty's dad meet one another and come together as a couple. I remember, according to my theory, you interfere with your parents for a speedy. They don't meet, they won't fall in love, they won't get married, and they won't have kids. That's why your older brother's just a friend. He now has to figure out how to make his parents fall in love with each other. So anyway, George, Valorant, she really likes you. She told me to tell you that she wants you to ask her to be a chairman of a CD. The story, the characters, the acting, the pacing, the way it all comes together, the music,
卡尔文？你为什么一直叫我卡尔文？嗯，这不就是你的名字吗？卡尔文·克莱恩？这名字写满了你的内裤呢。不，其实大家叫我马蒂。哦，很高兴认识你，卡尔文。马蒂？我喜欢那个场景的地方在于，你甚至能看到马蒂的不安，尽管他的母亲对他越来越感兴趣。我们在这里看到了哲学和心理学层面的含义。而所有这一切都发生在同一个时间点，多条线索同时推进，但它在喜剧、心理学甚至可能是哲学层面上都取得了巨大的成功。是的，这也是迪士尼不喜欢这部电影的地方。他们说，
the aesthetics, just how compelling and how gripping and how much you root for Marty and Doc from, you know, really early on the film to the end. The movie takes risks. One of the plot lines involves Marty meeting his own mom. His mom is a teenager and they are roughly the same age. To Marty's consternation, his mom becomes infatuated with him instead of with his dad. I've never seen Purple underwear before Calvin.
我们迪士尼不能拍一部关于母亲爱上自己儿子的电影，你知道的，我们可是迪士尼。我能理解迪士尼为什么会有这种反应，毕竟他们只是读了剧本，并没有看到真正拍出来、而且拍得如此出彩的电影。一旦你看到它在大银幕上呈现，与泽米吉斯的愿景完美契合，它就是那么搞笑，它就是行得通，而且你不会觉得（你知道的）恶心或尴尬。你知道的，它就是很成功。《回到未来》取得了巨大的成功。它是1985年票房最高的电影，全球票房收入近4亿美元。
Calvin, why do you keep calling me Calvin? Well, that is your name, isn't it? Calvin Klein? It's written all over your underwear. No, actually people. Call me Marty. Oh, please to meet you Calvin. Marty? What I love about that scene is that you can sort of see Marty's discomfort even as his mom is increasingly interested in him. And we are seeing the philosophical and psychological implications here. And all of that is happening at the same point where multiple things are happening, but it's happening at a very successful level, comedically, psychologically, and perhaps even philosophically. Yeah, and this is the aspect of the movie that Disney didn't like. They said,
影评人罗杰·埃伯特表示，《回到未来》充满了人情味、魅力和幽默感。罗伯特·泽米吉斯的职业生涯迎来了彻底的大翻转。他突然成了好莱坞最抢手的导演之一。与此同时，欧文·克什纳的职业生涯却归于沉寂。好吧，克什纳在《帝国反击战》之后可以说是登上了世界之巅，他也确实当之无愧。那是一部轰动之作，他完成得非常漂亮。
we Disney cannot make a movie about a mother falling in love with her son, you know, we're Disney. And I can understand why Disney would respond that way, having just read the screenplay and not seeing the movie actually made and made so brilliantly. Once you see it on screen in line with Semeckas' vision, it's just funny and it works and it doesn't seem you know, queasy or cringey. You know, it just works. Back to the future became a massive success. It was the highest grossing film in 1985,
但此后他的职业生涯并没有像人们预期的那样真正腾飞。他职业生涯的剩余部分只是拍了几部续集，然后就没有然后了。我们本以为泽米吉斯会被好莱坞淘汰。他被《魔茧》剧组解雇了。他当时可以说是跌入了世界的谷底。然后《绿宝石》大获成功，这给了他拍摄《回到未来》的机会，后者理所当然地成为了轰动一时的爆款。接着，他的名声被真正巩固为一位具有创新精神、极具创造力的天才电影人。当时在接受采访时，
earning nearly $400 million worldwide. Film critic Roger Ebert said back to the future offered humanity, charm, and humor. Robert Zemeckis' career had taken a complete U-turn. He was suddenly one of the most sought-after directors in Hollywood. Meanwhile, Irvin Kirschner's career had flatlined. Well, Kirschner was on top of the world after Empire Strikes Back as he should have been. It was a smash it and he did it beautifully well.
罗伯特·泽米吉斯被问及他是否愿意尝试非喜剧类电影。他回答说：“我希望能够尝试所有类型。”出于可以理解的原因，克什纳后来被称为“续集专家”。他拍出了一部大获成功的续集。而我认为，泽米吉斯在好莱坞和观众心中逐渐成了一个几乎无所不能的人。他在早期的作品中，仅通过几部电影就涉足了如此广泛的领域，并完成了
But his career after that didn't really take off in the way one might expect. The rest of his career was just a couple of sequels and that was it. And we would have expected Zamekis to exit Hollywood. He's got fired from Cucun. He was kind of on the bottom of the world. And then Romance in the Stone hit and it gave him the opportunity to make back the future, which of course became a smash hit. And then his reputation was truly cemented as a novel creative brilliant filmmaker. In an interview at the time,
如此多不同的尝试。甚至在一两部电影的范围内，比如《绿宝石》到《回到未来》，它们都如此复杂，包含着许多不同的元素，以至于我认为他并没有被框定在某种单一类型中。所以他的声誉仅仅是（你知道的）作为一名广泛意义上的电影制作人，这为他带来了许多机会，也让他具有极强的适应能力。罗伯特·泽米吉斯开始被视为才华横溢、极具胆识且不可预测。他的电影《谁陷害了兔子罗杰》将卡通人物与真人演员结合在了一起。
Robert Zemeckis was asked if he would ever want to make non-commodies. He replied, I would like to be able to do everything. Kirstner became known as sequel guy for understandable reasons. He made a smash hit sequel. Zemeckis, I think, came to be known in Hollywood and to audiences as someone who can almost do anything. He had this just in a few films in his early portfolio covered so much terrain and did
它集喜剧、动作、奇幻、谋杀悬疑于一身。到了90年代中期，那些来看每一部新的罗伯特·泽米吉斯电影的观众根本不知道自己会看到什么。好莱坞明星们都争相与这位导演合作。他接触的一切似乎都极具创新性。1994年，他拍了一部关于阿拉巴马州一个名叫福镇（阿甘）的男人的电影。他的名字叫福雷斯特。就像我一样。我用他爸爸的名字给他取了名。他有个爸爸叫福雷斯特·甘普。
so many different things. Even within the context of one or two movies, where Manson's turned back to the future, they were so kind of complicated, and had a lot of different elements to them, that I think he was not pigeonholed. So his reputation was just, you know, as a filmmaker broadly,
福雷斯特一生中，身边的人都告诉他他不够聪明。然而，当全世界都嘲笑他的迟钝时，笑到最后的却是福雷斯特。他的善良、他的慷慨，比那些嘲笑他的人的残酷更为强大。渐渐地，人们开始发现，由汤姆·汉克斯饰演的福雷斯特其实大智若愚。我不是个聪明人，但我知道什么是爱。罗伯特·泽米吉斯凭借此片赢得了奥斯卡最佳导演奖。
and that gave him a lot of opportunities, and made him really adaptable. Robert Zamekis came to be seen as brilliant, daring and unpredictable. His movie, Who Framed Roger Rabbit, had cartoon characters and live human actors. It was a comedy, action, fantasy, murder mystery. By the mid-90s, people who came to watch each new Robert Zamekis movie had no idea what they were going to get. Hollywood stars wanted to work with the director. Everything he touched seemed to be innovative. In 1994, he made a movie about an Alabama man named Forest Gump.
不久之后，他再次与汤姆·汉克斯合作，拍摄了一部奇怪的电影，讲述了一名联邦快递员工在坠机后被冲到一座荒岛上的故事。他唯一的同伴是一个排球。排球也是有感情的。你其实可以在他所有的这些电影中看到他早期作品的痕迹，因为他早期的作品是如此宽泛、多元且具有创新性。我的意思是这太迷人了，因为你可能会觉得，围绕着一个荒岛上的一个男人和一个排球，你其实做不出多少文章，然而这部电影却如此丰富、强烈，从头到尾都能牢牢抓住你的注意力。
His name's Forest. Like me. I named him after his daddy. He got a daddy named Forest Gump. All his life the people around Forest told him he wasn't smart. Yet, while the world mocked him for being slow, it was Forest who had the last laugh. His kindness, his generosity, was stronger than the cruelty of those who mocked him. In time, people came to see that forest, played by Tom Hanks, was wise, even if he wasn't smart. I'm not a smart man, but I know what love is." Robert Zamekis won an Oscar for Best Director.
这是又一部成功的电影，尽管仅仅通过阅读剧本、且在不知道罗伯特·泽米吉斯将要执导的情况下，你根本不会对它抱有成功的期待。在随后的几十年里，罗伯特·泽米吉斯一直是一位多产的电影人，制作了大量的电影和电视节目。与此同时，欧文·克什纳的职业生涯——起初看起来比罗伯特·泽米吉斯的职业生涯更有前途——却再也没有回到《帝国反击战》和《巡弋飞弹》那样的高峰。他于2010年去世。
Soon he teamed up again with Tom Hanks to make a strange movie about a FedEx employee who washes up on a deserted island after a plane crash. His only friend is a volleyball has feelings too. You can kind of see threads to his early work in all of these films because this early work was so broad broad diverse and novel. I mean it's fascinating because you would think that there's not much you can do with one guy on a on a on a deserted island and a volleyball and yet the movie is sort of rich and intense and holds your attention from start
那么，是什么造就了克什纳式的克什纳和泽米吉斯式的泽米吉斯？为什么有些创作者如同转瞬即逝的流星，而另一些人则发现自己处于持续成功的轨迹上？作为一名研究创造力的研究人员，贾斯廷对罗伯特·泽米吉斯这样的离群值是如何取得巨大成功的产生了浓厚的兴趣。我对看着创作者做他们所做的事情感到由衷的敬畏。作为电影、电视节目、书籍以及所有各种创意产业产品的粉丝，一想到这些东西都是由真人创造的，就觉得有点不可思议。更不可思议的是，
to finish. It's another film that just that works despite the fact that you wouldn't expect it to work if you just read the screenplay and you didn't know that Robert Zamekis was about to direct it. Over the next several decades, Robert Zamekis would remain a prolific filmmaker, producing a number of films and TV shows. Meanwhile, Oven Kushner's career, which had started out looking so much more promising than Robert Zemeckis's career, never returned to the highs of the Empire Strikes Back and never say never again.
一些创作者能够一遍又一遍地这样做，创造出我们喜爱、铭记、珍惜并愿意与他人讨论的东西。而且他们不知何故设法一直这样坚持下去。这有点像（你知道的）一种魔术，而我很想弄明白这个魔术是如何运作的。所以我将我的一生奉献于此，试图揭开创作者神秘的面纱，弄清楚他们实际上是如何构建创意并从无到有地将事情变成现实的。创意产业当然吸引了大量想要扬名立万的人。无数的人都想成为作家、电影制作人和音乐家。
He died in 2010. So what makes a Kushner a Kushner and a Zamekis a Zamekis? Why are some creators shooting stars that quickly burn out while others find themselves on a sustained trajectory of success? As a researcher who studies creativity, Justin became very interested in how outliers like Robert Zamekis achieve outside success. I'm just an awe of seeing creators do what they do. Being a fan of movies and TV shows and books and all the various creative industry products, it's just kind of amazing to think that these things were created by people. And even more amazing to think,
如果成功是可以预测的，你或许会期望看到数学家所说的正态分布。如果你按身高把人类排成一行，非常高和非常矮的人只占少数，大多数人都是平庸的。但在创意产业中，贾斯廷说，大多数人都是不成功的。只有一小撮人取得了短暂的成功。极少数人取得了持续的、巨大的成功。
some creators do this over and over again and create things that we love and remember and cherish and talk to about with other people. And they somehow managed to kind of keep doing it. It's a bit like, you know, a magic trick and wanted to understand how the magic trick works. And so that I've dedicated my my life figuring out, to kind of demystifying what creators do and how they actually make build creative ideas and make things happen from nothing. Creative industries, of course, draw large numbers of people who are looking to make a name for themselves. Inumerable people want to be writers, filmmakers, and musicians.
这就是我们讨论过的那个模式：幂律分布。幂律分布是一种高度偏态的分布。如果我们审视所有拥有一个或多个热门作品的创作者——这不包括那些热门作品为零的人，而这实际上占了绝大多数创作者。但如果我们只看那些足够幸运和有才华、能够取得一个热门作品的极小一部分创作者，其中一半甚至更多的人都将是“昙花一现”的代名词。换句话说，他们的整个职业生涯中恰好只有一个热门作品。只有极少数的创作者会有好几个
If success was predictable, you might expect to see what mathematicians call a normal distribution. If you line up human beings by height, the very tall and the very short are in the minority, most people are average. But in creative industries, Justin says, most people are average. But in creative industries, Justin says, most people are unsuccessful. A handful achieve brief success. A very tiny number achieve sustained, outside success.
甚至更多的热门作品。所以这是一种高度偏态的分布，大多数人只有一个、两个，也许三个。然后极少数人有几个或更多。当你考虑到总是有新的作家、电影制作人和音乐家在寻求崭露头角时，某些创作者的持续成功就更加令人困惑了。在这些创意产业中，由于人员流动极大、不断有新人涌入、竞争异常激烈且变化节奏快，成功变得更难以预测，随机性更高，创作者要维持成功也就更加困难。一种思考方式是，在创意产业中取得持续成功的人，
It's that pattern we talked about, the Power Law Distribution. Power Law Distribution is a very skewed distribution where if we look at all the creators that have one or more hits, so this doesn't count the people who have zero hits, which is actually the vast majority of creators. But if we just look at the small slice of critters who are fortunate and talented enough to get one hit, half or more are going to be one hit wonders. In other words, they're going to have exactly one hit in their entire career. And only a small handful of critters are going to be one-hit wonders. In other words, they're going to have exactly one hit in their entire career. And only a small handful of creators are going to have several more hits
已经通过了一场极其困难的障碍赛。第一个挑战是首先获得关注。如果你通过了第一个挑战，第二个障碍就是维持最初的成功。这些看起来可能相似的挑战，但事实上并非如此。稍后回来，贾斯廷的研究揭示了一个残酷的真相。
in their career. And so it's this very skewed distribution where most just have one, two, maybe three. And then very, very few have several or more. The sustained success of some creators is all the more puzzling when you consider that there are always new writers, filmmakers and musicians who are looking to make their mark. In these creative industries because things churn a lot and there's a constant new entrance and there's a high degree of competition and pace of change, success is much less predictable, there's more randomness, and it's more difficult for creators to be able to sustain success. One way to think about this is that people who achieve sustained success in creative industries
正是那个帮你跨过第一个障碍的东西，让跨过第二个障碍变得更加困难。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几年前，我采访了研究员霍曼·阿吉尼斯。他评估了各个领域中人们的表现。他发现成功分配不均。我们研究了研究人员、艺人、政治家，还研究了大学生运动员以及职业运动员。在所有这些类型的行业中，我们都发现一小撮超级明星表演者贡献了与其不成比例的产出。
have made it through an extremely difficult obstacle course. The first challenge is to get noticed at all. The second obstacle, if you make it past the first, is to sustain that initial success. These may seem like similar challenges, but in fact, they are not. When we come back, Justin's research uncovers a cruel truth.
如果你查看畅销书排行榜或音乐排行榜，你也会发现同样的现象。你会看到大量的更迭，这意味着源源不断的新进入者，但其中大多数都是昙花一现。就像流星一样，它们闪耀了一会儿，然后就消失了。你还会发现少数几位始终名列榜首的作家和音乐家。在斯坦福大学，贾斯廷·伯格对这种现象产生了好之。为什么有些创意艺术家能够获得暂时的成功，而另一些人却能持续成功？
The very thing that helps you get past the first obstacle makes it harder to get past the second. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Some years ago, I interviewed the researcher Homen Aguinness. He evaluated the performance of people in a wide variety of fields. He found that success was distributed unequally. We looked at researchers, we looked at entertainers, we looked at politicians, and we looked at collegiate as well as professional athletes. In each of these kinds of industries we found that is more minority of superstar performers contribute a disproportionate amount of the output.
为了试图回答这个问题，他将目光投向了娱乐产业的一个特定分支——音乐界。如果你有兴趣在一个创意产业的背景下研究持续成功，研究音乐有点像生物学家研究果蝇，因为你可以看到很多生命周期，这可以说是所有创意产业中
You can see the same thing for yourself if you look at the charts of bestselling books or the music charts. You'll see lots of churn, meaning a steady stream of new entrance, but most of these are one hit wonders. Like shooting stars, they shine brightly for a moment, and then vanish. You'll also find a small number of authors and musicians who consistently stay atop the charts. At Stanford University, Justin Berg was curious about why this happens. Why do some creative artists have momentary success, while others have sustained success?
变化最快、人员流动率最高的行业。贾斯廷进行了一项大规模研究，考察了那些从未成功的音乐人、只有一首热门歌曲的音乐人，以及不断产出热门歌曲的音乐人。他追踪了近7万名在1959年至2010年间与唱片公司签约的艺人。然后，他统计了他们有多少首歌曲成功打入了公告牌百强单曲榜。总共下来，他最终分析了300万首歌曲。你知道，在我的数据集中，如果你看看那些被各大唱片公司以及任何出过热门单曲的唱片公司签约的艺人，大约7万名艺人中，93%的人零热单。
To try to answer this question, he looked at one specific arm of the entertainment industry, the music business. If you're interested in studying sustained success in the context of a creative industry, studying music is a little bit like a biologist studying fruit flies because you get to see a lot of life cycles because it's arguably the fastest moving, highest churn industry of all the
为了试图回答这个问题，他将目光投向了娱乐产业的一个特定分支——音乐行业。如果你有兴趣在创意产业的背景下研究持续的成功，研究音乐有点像生物学家研究果蝇，因为你可以看到很多生命周期，因为它可以说是发展最快、人员流动率最高的行业之一
creative industries. Justin conducted a massive study that looked at musicians who never become successful, those who only had one hit song and those who generated hit after hit after hit. He tracked nearly 70,000 artists who had been signed by a label between the years of 1959 and 2010. Then he measured how many of their songs had cracked the Billboard Hot 100 list. In total, he ended up analyzing 3 million songs. You know, in my data set, if you look at artists who have been signed by major labels and any label that's had a hit, so about 70,000 artists, 93% have had zero hits.
只有7%的人有过一首或更多的热门单曲。在这7%的人中，大约有一半只有一首热单。在创意产业中一个非常一致的发现是，如果创作者真的有过热门作品，那么其中一半甚至更多的人最终都只是昙花一现。那么，人们过去都是通过什么方式来理解这一点的呢？我一会儿就想聊聊你的研究，但我想知道人们是如何试图理解这一现象的。我的意思是，我想至少有一种解释是，嗯，莎士比亚之所以是莎士比亚，
And only 7% have had one or more hits. And then about half of that 7% have only had one hit. A very consistent finding across creative industries is that half or more of creators are one hit wonders if they have a hit at all. And so what have been the ways people have tried to understand this? I want to get to your research in just a second, but I'm wondering how people have tried to understand this phenomenon. I mean, I think at least what explanation is, well, Shakespeare, a Shakespeare,
就是因为有些人生来就是某种创意天才，而当这些人出现时，他们就是那些能够持续成功的人。如果你能为我大致勾勒出你过去所遇到的一些解释这种罕见发现的理论。首先浮现脑海的一个想法是个人才华。
you have people who are just sort of creative geniuses, and when those people come along, they are the people who have sustained success. If you can just give me a painting to picture of what some of the theories were, that you've encountered in the past that explains sort of this unusual finding. One thought that comes to mind is individual talent.
即某些创作者在本质上、天生就比其他人更有才华。这是一种可能的解释。另一个是作品质量、产品的质量。研究文献中一个相当一致的发现是，高度成功的创作者会产出更多内容，他们创作更多作品，生产更多产品，而这增加了他们获得热门作品并维持长期成功职业生涯的几率。
That some creators are just inherently innately more talented than others. That's a possible explanation. Another one is quality of works, quality of products. It's a pretty consistent finding in the research literature that highly successful creators produce more content, they produce more works, they produce more products than that increases their odds
这里还有一个叫做“累积优势”的概念。这个观点是，一旦你取得了巨大的成功，你在面对每一张新专辑时就不再是从零开始。你可以在你这座成功的山峰之上再建一座更高的山。如果你是泰勒·斯威夫特或布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀，你知道的，你已经相当有名了，背后有强大的营销力量支持，而且你拥有一个庞大的粉丝群体，他们已经急不可耐地等待着你的下一张专辑发行。我们有很好的理论来解释他们是如何维持成功的。
of having hits and sustaining long career with hits. There's also the concept of something called cumulative advantage. This is the idea that once you have a lot of success, you're no longer starting from scratch with each new album. You can build on your mountain of success to create an even bigger mountain. If you're a Taylor Swift or Bruce Springsteen, you know, already quite famous and you have a lot of marketing muscle behind you and you have a fan base that's already a ravenous,
但那是在他们早已成为热门制造者、并且已经有了好几个热门作品之后很久的事了。那时我们知道，资源和机会确实会向处于最顶尖的1%中的1%的那类顶级创作者倾斜。但对于创作者最初是如何成为热门制造者的理论却比较少。
eager for your next album to drop. We have good theories to explain how they sustain success. But that's long after they've already become a hitmaker. They've had several more hits. Then we know that resources and opportunities accrue to that very lead group of the top 1% of the top 1% kind of creators. But there's fewer theories to kind of explain how creators become hitmakers to begin with.
我想知道，难道你没有被这些理论说服吗？我的意思是，每一种理论在某种程度上听起来至少都是合理的。这些我都挺买账的。所以我确实认为才华起到了一定作用，但我认为几乎所有拥有一两个热门作品的创作者都相当有才华。如果你仔细观察，以一种更宏大的方式去对比那些昙花一现的创作者与热门制造者的才华，才华似乎并不是全部的答案。也许有一点关系，但并非全部。我完全赞同数量也发挥了巨大作用。
And I'm wondering, were you not persuaded by these theories? I mean, each of them in some ways, at least sounds plausible. I've persuaded by all of them. So I do think talent plays some role, but I think that nearly all creators that have one or two hits are pretty darn talented. And if you take a closer look, you know, in a more grander way and try to kind of compare the talent of a lot of creators that become one hit wonders compared to hit makers, talent doesn't really seem to be the whole story. Maybe a little bit of it, but not the whole story. I totally buy that quantity also plays a big role.
这只是一种数学上的常识，你知道的，如果你有更多的产品，其中任何一个成为热门作品的可能性就会更高。但我不知道这是否能解释关于你究竟会成为昙花一现还是热门制造者的全部差异，才华也是如此。它解释了一部分。你确实必须不断地产出作品。你不能放弃。
That's just kind of a mathematical, you know, truism that if you have more products, the likelihood that you're going to have any one of them hit is higher. But I don't know that that explains all the variance and whether you become one hit wonder or hit maker, just like town. It explains some of it. You do have to keep producing work. You can't quit.
你不能气馁。但“数量”同样不能说明全部问题。当然，关于累积优势，这是社会科学中一个非常强有力的发现，即成功会孕育成功。所以对于那些已经成为热门制造者的人，我们可以比对新人的确定性更高地预测他们的下一张专辑、下一部电影或下一本书会表现良好。但我的研究切入点是：你究竟是如何一步步走到那个层面的？
You can't give up. But Quaid also doesn't tell the whole story. And of course, with cumulative advantage, that's a very robust finding in social science that the success begets success. So those who have already become hitmakers, we can predict that their next album or their next film, their next book is going to do well with more certainty than a new entrant. But my research kind of enters in of how do you get to that level to begin with.
当贾斯廷开始着手探讨他的问题时，他有了一个想法。大多数分析成功的人都在关注创作者那些成功的歌曲和电影。当我们想到罗伯特·泽米吉斯的职业生涯时，我们会想到《回到未来》、《阿甘正传》和《荒岛余生》。但是他早期的作品呢？那些并不成功的作品。像《二手车》这样的电影，或者那部关于珍珠港袭击事件的喜剧。这让我意识到，研究人员其实并没有真正审视过创作者的作品集是如何预测其未来成功的。我们在文献中称之为路径依赖。因此，路径依赖的观点是，在一个过程早期发生的事情，会限制你在该过程结束时拥有的选项范围。
As Justin began to approach his question, he had a thought. Most people analyzing success looked at the successful songs and movies of creators. When we think of Robert Zemeckis' career, we think of back to the future and forest gum and cast away. But what about his older work? The work that wasn't successful. Movies like used cars or that comedy about the Pearl Harbor attacks. And it struck me that researchers have not really looked at how a creator's passport folio is predicting future success. We'd call that in the literature path dependence. So path dependence is the idea that what happens early in a process can limit the range of options you have by the end of that process.
正当贾斯汀开始着手解决他的问题时，他脑海中闪过一个想法。大多数分析成功的人都关注创作者成功的歌曲和电影。当我们想到罗伯特·泽米吉斯的职业生涯时，我们会想到《回到未来》、《阿甘正传》和《荒岛余生》。但是他早期的作品呢？那些不成功的作品。像《used cars》或那部关于珍珠港袭击的喜剧之类的电影。令我震惊的是，研究人员并没有真正研究过创作者的作品集是如何预测未来的成功的。我们在文献中称之为路径依赖。因此，路径依赖是指在过程早期发生的事情可能会限制该过程结束时可供选择的范围。
And as a creativity researcher, what I looked at the existing literature on sort of sustained success and creative careers, most of the research was looking at, you know, how creative a given product is at a given time, you know, how novel it is or how much variety it adds to a creator's portfolio. And then using that to try to predict whether that product would be successful. It didn't look at path dependence, which would be how does past products. So the products that the creator has generated and released to the market in the past, how does that influence future performance? And so it dawned on me that that's just a huge,
作为一个创造力研究人员，当我查看现有的关于持续成功和创意职业生涯的文献时，大多数研究都在关注，你知道，在特定时间某个创意产品有多大程度的创意，你知道，它有多新颖，或者它为创作者的作品集增添了多少多样性。然后用这些来试图预测该产品是否会成功。它没有研究路径依赖，也就是过去的产品的状况。也就是说，创作者过去制作并发布到市场上的产品，会如何影响未来的表现？所以我突然意识到，这正是一个巨大的、
overlooked factor that portfolios could be carriers of history that end up having enduring implications beyond that moment when each product was released. And so I brought that perspective to bear on the music industry. Of course, one reason it's very hard to analyze how a musician's initial songs in career might offer clues to her later success is that this is very hard to do on a massive scale. So sure, you can analyze the early songs of the Beatles or the early songs of Taylor Swift
被忽视的因素，作品集可以成为历史的载体，最终产生持久的影响，超越每个产品发布的那一刻。因此，我将这种视角应用到音乐产业中。当然，很难分析音乐家的早期歌曲和职业生涯如何为其后来的成功提供线索的原因之一，是在大规模上做到这一点非常困难。所以当然，你可以分析披头士乐队早期的歌曲，或者泰勒·斯威夫特早期的歌曲，
once you know they are superstars. But if there is useful information in the early careers of musicians, it's not enough to analyze the superstars. You have to analyze everyone so you can figure out what the superstars are doing differently. You have to study the vast majority of musicians who never have a hit, the smaller number who have a single hit, and the tiny minority who have sustained success. The only way to do this is by computing enormous amounts of information. Justin algorithmically dissected millions of songs by thousands of artists
一旦你知道他们是超级巨星。但是，如果音乐家早期的职业生涯中存在有用的信息，仅仅分析超级巨星是不够的。你必须分析每一个人，这样才能弄清楚超级巨星们的做法有何不同。你必须研究绝大多数从未有过热门歌曲的音乐家，研究少数只有一首热门歌曲的音乐家，以及极少数获得持续成功的音乐家。做到这一点的唯一方法是计算海量的信息。贾斯汀用算法剖析了成千上万位艺术家的数百万首歌曲，
into a number of different sonic features from tempo to time signature. He wanted to see whether they were patterns common to musicians who had no hits, musicians who were one hit wonders, and musicians who scored hit after hit after hit. He looked at two ideas. Novelty and Variety. Novelty is how unique a song is compared to the other songs in the marketplace at the time.
从节奏到拍号，将其分解为许多不同的声音特征。他想看看那些没有热门歌曲的音乐家、一曲成名的音乐家以及一再创造热门歌曲的音乐家之间是否存在共同的模式。他研究了两个概念：新颖性和多样性。新颖性是指一首歌与当时市场上其他歌曲相比有多独特。
So basically, novelty is how unique a song is compared to the recent songs in the marketplace at the time. So basically novelty is how unique a song is compared to the recent hits in the market. And variety is how different your songs within your portfolio are to one another. So variety is internal to the creator's own portfolio. We'll come back to the idea of variety in a moment. But looking first at novelty, you might think it would be a predictor of success. If you want to make a mark for yourself, doesn't it make sense to come up with something
所以基本上，新颖性是指一首歌与当时市场上最近的歌曲相比有多独特。所以基本上，新颖性是指一首歌与市场上最近的热门歌曲相比有多独特。多样性是指你作品集中的歌曲彼此之间有多大不同。所以多样性是创作者自身作品集内部的属性。我们一会儿再回过头来探讨多样性的概念。但首先来看新颖性，你可能会认为它是成功的预测指标。如果你想为自己树立名声，想出一个
startlingly new and daring that no one has ever done before? That might make sense intuitively, but it fails to recognize that songs and genres that are popular are popular for a very simple reason. Audiences want to listen to them. When you give audiences something very new, they're likely to go, what the heck is this? Novelty is a negative predictor of initial success, meaning that the creators who release novel songs are less likely to ever have a hit. They're more likely to strike out and we never really hear about them. So, if the creator builds a novel portfolio, that's a bunch of unique songs that sort of stand out compared to what's hit recently in the market, they are less likely to ever have a hit in their career. Conversely, creators who build typical portfolios, so songs that sound very similar to what's
惊人的新点子，做前人从未做过的大胆尝试，难道不是很有道理吗？这从直觉上讲得通，但它没有认识到流行歌曲和流派之所以流行，原因非常简单。听众想听它们。当你给听众一些非常新的东西时，他们可能会想：这到底是什么鬼？新颖性是初始成功的负面预测指标，这意味着发布新颖歌曲的创作者永远不会有热门歌曲的可能性更低。他们更有可能铩羽而归，而我们再也不会真正听到他们的消息。因此，如果创作者构建了一个新颖的作品集，也就是一堆与市场上最近的热门歌曲相比显得与众不同的独特歌曲，他们职业生涯中拥有热门歌曲的可能性就会降低。相反，创造典型作品集的创作者，也就是那些听起来与当时流行歌曲非常相似的歌曲，
popular at the time, they are more likely to have a hit in their career, they're more likely to have an initial hit, but they're also more likely then to become a one-hit wonder after that initial hit. Think back to the story of Irvin Kushner. Star Wars might have been a novel idea when it came out, but the idea of an intergalactic space war was hardly novel in the Empire Strikes Back. A sequel is pretty much the definition of a movie style that is not novel. Compared this to Robert Zemeckis, whose early movies were pretty unusual, and were all flops. 1941, a comedy about the bombing of Pearl Harbor is as novel as it gets, and it received
他们在职业生涯中出现热门歌曲的可能性更高，他们更有可能获得初期的成功，但在此之后，他们也更有可能变成昙花一现的“一曲歌手”。回想一下欧文·库什纳的故事。《星球大战》刚上映时可能是一个新颖的创意，但《帝国反击战》中间星际战争的概念就谈不上新颖了。续集几乎就是一部风格并不新颖的电影的代名词。将此与罗伯特·泽米吉斯进行对比，他的早期电影非常不寻常，而且全部惨遭扑街。《1941》是一部关于轰炸珍珠港的喜剧，可谓新颖之至，但它却得到了
a stony face response from audiences. So if you want to produce a hit, novelty is risky. But here's the catch. When it comes to building sustained success, novelty now becomes a huge advantage. So if you do manage to build a novel portfolio and then have an initial hit, that novel portfolio acts as sort of a resource for sustained success. So those who reach their initial hits with a novel portfolio are more likely to have additional hits. In other words, if creators are able to beat the odds and find success with novel ideas,
观众冷若冰霜的反应。所以如果你想制作一部热门作品，新颖性是有风险的。但问题就在这里。当谈到建立持续的成功时，新颖性现在变成了一个巨大的优势。因此，如果你确实设法构建了一个新颖的作品集，并随后获得了最初的成功，那么这个新颖的作品集就会成为持续成功的某种资源。因此，那些凭借新颖作品集获得最初热门歌曲的人更有可能获得更多热门歌曲。换句话说，如果创作者能够打破常规，凭借新颖的创意取得成功，
that novelty becomes the driver for further success. There's two reasons for this, and I call them internal learning and external expectations. So internal learning is just the fact that you've learned more from that novel portfolio than you would have if you had built a typical portfolio. You learn more and you also learn more adaptable lessons. It's so for external expectations, that's about how the outside world thinks of you. So this is the audience and key gatekeepers in the industry, whether it's executives or disc jockeys or agents, producers, etc. And so if you have built a novel portfolio and then had an initial hit with that novel portfolio, you are now seen as someone who's, you know, an innovator and, you know, people are more open to you coming
这种新颖性就会成为进一步成功的驱动力。原因有两个，我称之为内部学习和外部期望。内部学习只是这样一个事实：你从那个新颖的作品集中学到的东西，要比你构建一个典型作品集学到的东西更多。你学到的更多，而且学到的是适应性更强的经验。至于外部期望，那是关于外界如何看待你的。这就是听众和行业中的关键把关人，无论是高管、唱片骑师、经纪人、制作人等。因此，如果你构建了一个新颖的作品集，然后凭借该新颖作品集获得了最初的热门歌曲，你现在就被视为一个创新者，你知道的，人们会更加接受你的新音乐，
out with new music. And it essentially makes you more adaptable over time. I mean, in some ways, this sounds like the story of Robert Zemeckis. I think so. You know, I want to hold your hand was not super novel, but used cars certainly was, romantic in the stone, certainly was, 1941, certainly was. And I think he learned a lot from all these films. And then he took all that, everything that he learned, and he put it in back to the future.
这本质上使你随着时间的推移适应能力更强。我的意思是，在某些方面，这听起来像是罗伯特·泽米吉斯的故事。我想是的。你知道的，《一气呵成》并不是超级新颖，但《重振雄风》绝对是，《绿宝石浪漫曲》绝对是，《1941》绝对是。我想他从所有这些电影中学到了很多东西。然后他把所有这些，他学到的一切，都放回了《回到未来》中。
And that's, you know, became his first smash hit. Right, and then the fact is that he had this experience with all these different things and that helped him as he was building, you know, Castaway and Forest Gump and contact and other movies. Yeah, I think both Thurne and external expectations helped, you know, serve his sustained success. So he learned something from that early portfolio, but then also the outside world came to see him as this brilliant novel creative filmmaker who can do anything.
这就是，你知道的，成为了他的第一部轰动之作。没错，事实是他拥有所有这些不同事物的经验，这在他构建《荒岛余生》、《阿甘正传》、《接触未来》和其他电影时对他有所帮助。是的，我认为内在学习和外部期望都有助于，你知道的，促成他的持续成功。所以他从早期作品集中学到了东西，但随后外界也开始视他为这位才华横溢、充满新意的创意电影制作人，能够胜任任何事情。
So then it allowed him to pursue a broader array of films after his initial hits. Notice the cruel irony here. The very thing that makes you more likely to have initial success works against you when it comes to sustained success. The very thing that helps you have sustained success works against you when it comes to getting your initial breakthrough. Here was an explanation for the Power Law distribution and music. To become a superstar, you need to overcome two obstacles, where your chances of overcoming the first reduce your chances of overcoming the second.
因此，这使他在初次成功之后能够追求更广泛的电影类型。请注意这里残酷的讽刺。正是那个让你更有可能获得初步成功的东西，在追求持续成功时却会对你产生反作用。正是那个帮助你获得持续成功的东西，在试图实现最初的突破时却会阻碍你。这里有一个对音乐中幂律分布的解释。要成为超级巨星，你需要克服两个障碍，其中你克服第一个障碍的机会减少了你克服第二个障碍的机会。
Justin has looked at two singers who exemplify this idea. Rebi Jackson and Janet Jackson. Rebi and Janet Jackson got their start in a very similar way. They were introduced to the world on the TV show The Jackson's, which also introduced Michael Jackson in The Jackson 5 to The World. That was in the late 70s. And then both Rebbe and Janet Jackson had their debuts as solo artists in the early to mid 1980s.
贾斯汀观察了两位体现这一理念的歌手：芮比·杰克逊和珍妮·杰克逊。芮比和珍妮·杰克逊以非常相似的方式出道。她们通过电视节目《杰克逊家族》进入大众视野，该节目也将迈克尔·杰克逊和杰克逊五人组带入了世界。那是在70年代末。随后，芮比和珍妮·杰克逊都在80年代初到中期作为独唱艺术家首次亮相。
Rebbe released her debut album in 1984. It contained the hit song, Centipede. Around the same time, Rebbe's younger sister, Janet, released her own debut album. Both of them actually started off pretty successfully. They both actually had a top 100 hit on their debut albums. Now from there, their careers took very different trajectories. Rebi, by Justin's calculations, was a one-hit wonder. None of her subsequent songs came close to the success of Centipede.
芮比在1984年发行了她的首张专辑。其中包含了热门歌曲《Centipede》。大约在同一时间，芮比的妹妹珍妮发行了自己的首张专辑。两人的起步其实都相当成功。她们的首张专辑都打入了排行榜前100名。从那时起，她们的职业生涯走向了截然不同的轨迹。根据贾斯汀的计算，芮比是一位“一曲歌手”。她随后的所有歌曲都没有一首能接近《Centipede》的成功。
And of course, Janet Jackson has become one of the best selling artists of all time, with 41 hits and counting. And how do you think their backgrounds in terms of novelty and variety speak to the research that you have done, Justin? So their initial portfolio, so their portfolio at the time of their initial hits were, of course, their debut albums because they both got their first hits from their debut albums. So we can do a pretty good head-to-head comparison.
当然，珍妮·杰克逊已经成为有史以来最畅销的艺术家之一，拥有41首热门歌曲，并且还在增加。贾斯汀，你认为她们在创新性和多样性方面的背景如何说明你所做的研究？因此，她们最初的作品集，也就是她们获得最初热门歌曲时的作品集，当然就是她们的首张专辑，因为她们的第一首热门歌曲都来自首张专辑。所以我们可以做一个很好的直接对比。
As it turns out, this is what my model would predict, so Janet scores higher in novelty than Rebi. And that song that Rebi had in 1984 was, I understand, actually Michael Jackson, who was a huge star at the time, actually helped to write and produce the song. And it sounds a little bit like Michael Jackson. It has his signature all over it. So that speaks in some ways to what you're talking about in terms of the song having, you know, star appeal, but not a lot of novelty.
事实证明，这正是我的模型所预测的，珍妮在创新性上的得分高于芮比。据我了解，芮比在1984年推出的那首歌，实际上是当时的大明星迈克尔·杰克逊帮忙创作和制作的。听起来确实有点像迈克尔·杰克逊。到处都是他标志性的风格。这在某种程度上说明了你所谈论的关于这首歌具有，你知道的，明星吸引力但创新性不足的问题。
Exactly. novelty is both an advantage and a disadvantage for creators. If you're a creator with conventional ideas, you probably won't have long-term success. But if you're a creator with unconventional ideas, you'll have a hard time getting those ideas off the ground in the first place. There's this diameter trade-off between those two approaches. Do you produce songs that are different from the market, or do you produce songs that sound similar to what's been recently popular? Because of this trade-off, if you're a new creator, a new artist in the music industry,
没错。对于创作者来说，新颖性既是优势也是劣势。如果你是一个带有传统观念的创作者，你可能不会取得长期的成功。但如果你是一个带有非传统观念的创作者，你首先很难让这些创意落地生根。这两种方法之间存在着这种 diametral（截然相反）的权衡。你是制作与市场不同的歌曲，还是制作听起来与最近流行的歌曲相似的歌曲？正是因为这种权衡，如果你是音乐界的一个新创作者，一个新艺术家，
trying to decide how to construct your portfolio, you actually can't maximize your odds of becoming a hitmaker without simultaneously increasing your odds of having zero hits in your career. It helps explain why music and similar creative industries are so high-churned, how they chew up and spit out creators so quickly. We end up with this bizarre distribution of a lot of one-hit wonders and very few hitmakers. I can imagine that some creators are going to say while I have another hack around the conundrum that Justin is posing, and the hack is to basically try and get initial success by being conventional and then switch to being creative afterwards. Does that work?
试图决定如何构建你的作品集，你实际上无法在不增加职业生涯中零热曲几率的同时，最大化自己成为热门歌曲制造者的几率。这有助于解释为什么音乐和类似的创意产业人员流动率如此之高，为什么它们如此迅速地吞噬并淘汰创作者。我们最终得到了这种奇怪的分布：许多“一曲歌手”和极少数的热门歌曲制造者。我可以想象，一些创作者会说，我还有另一个对策来解决贾斯汀提出的难题，这个对策就是基本上试图通过保持传统来获得最初的成功，然后再转向具有创意。这行得通吗？
What my research would suggest is no no, that wouldn't work. That the path dependence gets triggered at the time of the initial hit and that your portfolio becomes a carrier of history that really kind of sticks with you for the rest of your career. Can it be done? Sure, it can be done. But the odds are really stacked against you
我的研究表明，不，行不通。路径依赖在初次成功时就被触发了，你的作品集变成了历史的载体，在你的余生中一直伴随着你。这能做到吗？当然，可以做到。但如果你在职业生涯早期拥有一个典型的作品集，
if you have a typical portfolio early in your career, because the industry is going to pass you by pretty quickly. You're going to be known for that sound. People are going to associate you with that particular milieu and as new sounds, new artists inevitably enter the marketplace, you'll likely be left behind regardless of the effort that you put in. you'll likely be left behind regardless of the effort that you put in. Creative industries are marked by very high levels of change. Audiences want what they want until they don't. To put this another way, musicians and movie makers who have sustained success are able to evolve with the tastes of their audience.
成功的几率对你非常不利，因为这个行业会很快把你抛在脑后。你会因为那种声音而被人们铭记。人们会将你与特定的环境联系起来，随着新声音、新艺术家不可避免地进入市场，无论你付出多少努力，你都可能会被时代抛弃。无论你付出多少努力，你都可能会被抛在后面。创意产业的特点是极高的变革水平。听众想要他们想要的，直到他们不再想要。换句话说，获得持续成功的音乐人和电影制作人能够随着受众品味的演变而演变。
Romancing the stone, for example, had a damsel and distress theme that might not go over well with audiences today. Back to the future, had stereotypical references to Libyan terrorists that sound xenophobic today. To be a successful artist over time, you have to change with the times, and this is where having a fairly limited repertoire in your early work can make it difficult to compete with new entrants who are closer to the zeitgeist. So what is a creator to do?
例如，《绿宝石浪漫曲》有一个落难美人的主题，这在今天的观众中可能不太受欢迎。《回到未来》中有对利比亚恐怖分子的刻板印象，在今天听起来带有仇外情绪。要随着时间的推移成为一名成功的艺术家，你必须与时俱进，而正是在这里，早期作品中相对有限的 repertoire（曲目库）会使你难以与更贴近时代精神的新进入者竞争。那么创作者该怎么做呢？
Stick to the conventional and run the risk of becoming a one-hit wonder? Or try the novel? And risk becoming a no-hit failure. This is where the second dimension Justin studied may come in useful. Novelty looks at how unusual the creator is. Variety examines the creator's range. One thing to keep in mind is that variety is a way to offset some of the trade-off with novelty. So if you come out with a really novel sounding song, but then you just do a whole album of
坚持传统，冒着变成“一曲歌手”的风险？还是尝试新颖？并冒着零热门歌曲失败的风险。这就是贾斯汀研究的第二个维度派上用场的地方。新颖性着眼于创作者的不寻常程度。多样性则检验创作者的涉猎范围。需要记住的一点是，多样性是抵消新颖性带来的一些权衡的一种方式。因此，如果你推出一首听起来非常新颖的歌曲，但随后你只制作了一整张专辑的
songs that sound like that one novel song, that's a portfolio that's high novelty but low in variety. And what's more optimal is to have a, you know, that first album or first two albums, rate high novelty. So you want those songs to sound different from what's popular at the time, but have a wide variety of novel songs. So you want them to sound different in different ways.
听起来像那首新颖歌曲的歌曲，那这就是一个新颖性高但多样性低的作品集。更理想的做法是，你知道的，让第一张专辑或前两张专辑在创新性上得分很高。所以你希望这些歌曲听起来与当时流行的大不相同，但同时要具备各种各样的新颖歌曲。所以你希望它们以不同的方式听起来有所不同。
And that's one way to try to overcome this thorny tradeoff with novelty. And so we see that with Simecus. He, you know, he has novel films early in his career, but they're very different from one another. And so that increased the odds that anyone would be a hit, and indeed we saw that with romance in the stone, that it was a highly novel film that ended up being a hit. It makes logical sense. Trying new things decreases your odds of initial success, but trying lots
这是试图克服新颖性这一棘手权衡的一种方法。我们在泽米吉斯身上看到了这一点。你知道的，他在职业生涯早期拍过新颖的电影，但它们彼此非常不同。因此，这增加了任何一部作品成为热门电影的几率，事实也确实如此，我们在《绿宝石浪漫曲》中看到了这一点，它是一部最终大获成功的高度新颖的电影。这在逻辑上讲得通。尝试新事物会降低你获得初次成功的几率，但尝试许多
of different new things can increase your odds of initial success. But trying lots of different new things can increase your odds of initial success. If you throw a lot of different novel ideas at the wall, the likelihood that one of them will stick goes up. So you can't completely offset the thorny trade-off with novelty, but if you do a variety of novel things, it's more likely that any one of them is going to be a hit and going to succeed, and that's really what Simecast did.
不同类型的新事物可以增加你获得初次成功的几率。如果你把许多不同的新奇想法抛向墙壁，其中一个能粘住的可能性就会上升。所以你无法完全消除新颖性带来的棘手权衡，但如果你做各种各样新颖的事情，它们中的任何一个成为热门并取得成功的可能性就会更高，而这正是泽米吉斯所做的。
Justin Berg studies organizational behavior at the Stanford Graduate School of Business. Justin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, this was a lot of fun. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run song here today is Harmony Gerudic at Descript.
贾斯汀·伯格在斯坦福大学商学院研究组织行为学。贾斯汀，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，这非常有趣。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的片尾曲由 Descript 的 Harmony Gerudic 创作。
Descript is a software program that we use here at Hidden Brain to transcribe our interviews and write rough drafts of our scripts. We had some questions about changes that discriples rolling out, so Harmony put together a training to walk our team through those changes. She was very patient with our questions and genuinely interested in hearing our feedback and suggestions. Thank you Harmony for your help. We're truly grateful. If you love the ideas that we feature on the show, then please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus, our subscription channel, available on Apple Podcasts.
Descript 是我们在《隐藏的大脑》中使用的软件程序，用于转录我们的采访并编写剧本初稿。我们对 Descript 正在推出的更改有一些疑问，因此 Harmony 组织了一次培训，带领我们团队了解这些更改。她对我们的问题非常耐心，并且真心有兴趣听取我们的反馈和建议。谢谢 Harmony 的帮助。我们真的非常感激。如果你喜欢我们在节目中介绍的观点，请考虑加入 Hidden Brain Plus，这是我们在苹果播客上推出的订阅频道。
You'll find new episodes not available anywhere else, plus the chance to have your questions answered by the researchers we feature on the show. Find Hidden Brain Plus on the Apple Podcasts app or go to Apple.co slash Hidden Brain to try it for free. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你将找到在其他地方找不到的新剧集，还有机会让节目中介绍的研究人员回答你的问题。在苹果播客应用中搜索 Hidden Brain Plus，或者访问 Apple.co 斜杠 Hidden Brain 免费试用。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。